et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
hervé morin bonjour bon je vais aussi
beaucoup d'être avec nous président de
la régie sur un billet je dis bonjour
président des centristes et on dit
toujours attiré un billet puisque c'est
une table et en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale et tirer un
billet qui est donc le rédacteur en chef
de paris la rente dans quel temps il
fait à rouen monsieur habillé il fait
très beau comme un dieu d'un pays en
faillite ou de mauvaise foi année encore
cette émission en parlant de la crise
sanitaire
évidemment et jean castex qui a dit hier
qu'on était dans une sorte de troisième
vague avec la question des variants est
ce qu'on est prêt à l'affronter sa
troisième vague pour vous écouter très
clairement on a aujourd'hui une très
forte tension hospitalier avant centre
de région je vois même la normandie le
taux d'incidence augmente les capacités
de réanimation sont de plus en plus
sollicitée est donc très clairement on
assiste à un vrai regain de l'épidémie
malheureusement et ça c'est ces espèces
de course entre la vaccination et est ce
ce maudit virus corps que vous êtes
inquiet sur la situation dans votre
région dont on paye je suis inquiet
d'une part bien sûr pour des réseaux
sanitaires et ce surtout inquiet aussi
pour les conséquences économiques
quand je vois à la fois les engagements
financiers considérables que l'état et
la région ont pu mettre pour sauver des
boîtes des boîtiers elle est très bien
il ya un an et donc on sait boîte là on
sollicitait beaucoup leur trésorerie
elle allait plutôt bien
la reprise se fait sur un certain nombre
de secteurs mais d'autres restent encore
très atteints et donc je me dis il faut
pas que ça dure encore des mois et des
mois parce qu'on va arriver une
catastrophe économique et donc social
derrière travail revenir sur ces
questions économiques et sociales mais
pour finir sur le confinement qui semble
quasi inéluctable en ile-de-france ans
on écoute ce qu'a dit jean castex y est
ce que pour vous il doit être complétée
de mesures de limitation des
déplacements ce confinement pour éviter
qu'ils aient des parisiens qui viennent
par exemple dans votre région normande
peut-être enfin je n'ai pas l'ensemble
des paramètres qui me permet de pouvoir
prendre position sur ces sujets là s'il
le faut faisons le mais clairement il
faut temps possible mettre les gens
télétravail autant que possible réduire
les risques de contamination reprendre
je l'espère la vaccination le plus
rapidement possible parce que très
franchement la décision de la suspension
de la vaccination je n'ai pas encore
rencontré quelqu'un en normandie qui
comprenait cette mesure soit il ya des
éléments qu'on ne connaît pas et que la
presse ne nous a pas donné
et dans ce cas là on veut bien
comprendre mais il ya quand même deux
choses la première c'est ce sentiment de
suivisme de la france à l'égard d' le
par rapport à l'allemagne
j'en profite pour dire que que pour
l'europe cette crise sanitaire sera un
rude coup et sur le projet européen
parce qu'on a vu à la fois l'égoïsme des
nations la capacité de l'union
européenne de répondre efficacement à la
question de la vaccination par rapport
aux états nations
ces questions là vont se dire c'est un
coup dur pour l'unité de l'union
européenne pour non c'est un coup dur
sur le projet européen est ce qu'on a
voulu en faire parce qu'on a vu des pays
qui chacun décidé de traiter ça à leur
façon
les allons voir les chinois les hôtes
les russes et 3e et si on trouvait des
vaccins je rappelle ce qu'on a vécu
aussi sur les masques au préalable donc
le la question du projet européen le
projet européen après un rude coup à
travers cette crise parce que l'europe
n'a pas montré non plus disons le
clairement une efficacité considérable
alors après il ya la question du genre
juste pour finir là-dessus quand jean
castex d'hier que l'europe doit montrer
les crocs notamment sur astrazeneca il a
raison pas non plus la question pour moi
le alors c'est toujours facile après de
refaire l'histoire je reconnais mais
mais j'ai eu entre payer un vaccin un
peu plus cher et s'étire et les coûts et
les prix quand la question c'est faire
en sorte qu'on sorte plus rapidement de
cette crise je pense que le raisonnement
est assez simple même s'il faut
surveiller un peu les vaccins il valait
mieux le faire pour avoir un maximum de
vaccins et mater vacciner un maximum de
personnes parce que ça coûte moins cher
pour le pays économiquement socialement
et même humainement parce que on vit
quand même et une terrible épreuve est
donc le raisonnement n'a pas été le bon
et deuxièmement très clairement l'europe
est en retard en matière de vaccination
par rapport à beaucoup d'autres pays
je termine sur astrazeneca moi j'ai des
choses que je comprends pas d'une part
il ya toujours cette question entre les
risques liés des risques éventuels liés
astrazeneca et le coût de l'arrêt de la
vaccination
très clairement il faut quand même
mettre en balance ces deux éléments
prouvant clairement il fallait pas
suspendre la vaccination écouter sauce
ya des éléments que ne connaissait que
nous ne connaissons pas mais j'ai pas eu
encore les caméras règlement il faut
fermer quand il ya 17 millions 15
millions 16 millions de britanniques qui
sont vaccinés et qu'on vous dit par
rapport à la population générale n'y a
pas plus de quatre ans bauzou vous dites
mais pourquoi on arrête cette
vaccination fait une erreur politique
mais on a le sentiment que ça donne
c'est des pions des pays européens
affolé un espèce de sentiment de panique
tout ça a tout de même et très
interrogeant quoi thierry
à une question sur la vaccination pour
justement il ya quelques semaines ou
nourricier beaucoup d'espoir sur les
vaccins sur la mise sur le marché de
nombreux vaccins
là le quatrième est suspendu pour
l'instant sur le territoire français
parce que vous espériez pouvoir acheter
des doses de vaccin pour justement
vacciner en normandie ce que vous
appeliez ceux qui font vivre l'économie
les actifs les vins les 20 60 ans qui
sont pas prévues de comme les personnes
prioritaires à vacciner ou est-ce que
vous en êtes aujourd'hui des discussions
justement et des potentiels laboratoire
qui avant l'été ou au début de l'automne
pourrait éventuellement prendre le
risque de vendre des vaccins directement
une collectivité locale a coûté tient un
billet moi j'ai toujours dit comme on
l'a fait sur les masques je vous
rappelle que nous avons tout de même
fourni 2 millions de masques aux
personnels de santé en normandie
parce que il manquait des masques dans
les hôpitaux on a fourni je vous
rappelle plus de 2 millions de masques
aussi aux acteurs économiques pour leur
permettre de reprendre au moment où cela
était possible et la première question
que vous me posez tous les chefs
d'entreprise comme vous souvenez c'était
mais je peux pas reprendre le boulot
tant que je ne suis pas en capacité de
fournir des masques à mes collaborateurs
bien après on en a fourni aux
collectivités locales et donc ma
démarche sur les vaccins était la même
ma démarche n'était pas d'être en
confiance avec l'état ma démarche était
d'être en complémentarité donner un coup
de main
faire en sorte que là on peut être utile
on le soient sous les masques j'ai pas
cherché à mettre en place mon propre
dispositif de distribution avec mes
critères j'ai appelé la dg de la rs j'ai
dit voilà vous me direz là où vous
trouvez qu'il faut fournir des masques
et c'est vous qui décideraient de les
mettre là où vous le souhaitez bien j'ai
à l'époque dit cela parce que regarder
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
vont produire des vaccins
l'une qui va bientôt je l'espère en
produire aussi sur un autre vaccin qui
n'est pas encore sur le marché qui est
le curve ac est donc le raisonnement que
je tiens c'est que mon sentiment
sauf malheur sur des mcsa qui seraient
obligés d'être retirée c'est qu'on va
avoir à partir de
de l'été massivement des vaccins qui
seront produire en europe et dans le
monde et même en france et donc les
discussions que j'ai eues et et
industriels pour tout vous dire j'en ai
eu
c'est de dire sur des capacités marginal
on doit pouvoir éventuellement trouver
des vaccins après il faut que j'en ai le
droit c'est un autre sujet le droit d'en
acheter ce que le gouvernement pour
l'instant ne nous autorise pas comme ils
ne nous autorise pas sur les vaccins par
ailleurs et par ailleurs c'est le rythme
de la vaccination en france parce que je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais au
début les actifs les 40 60 il était pas
du tout axim et puis après on a eu
différentes stratégies et ensuite on a
eu le prix dans la république qui nous a
expliqué qu'avant la fin de l'été tout
le monde seraient vaccinées en france
alors offrir un public au milieu santé
chez plus l'un des deux ponts donc si
tout le monde est vaccinés durant l'été
au problème est réglé donc on verra bien
mais je continue à penser que d'aider
des régions pourrait apporter un coup de
main supplémentaire
là où on pourrait trouver des marges des
vaccins marginalement dans le cadre des
commandes qui sont faites questions sur
les écoles les lycées thierry oui mais
en juin dernier vous étiez un petit peu
même si peu agacé de voir la
précipitation avec laquelle le
gouvernement vous à vous inciter à
ouvrir les lycées pour quelques jours
avant l'ag vacances d'été est ce que
finalement avec le recul c'était déjà
une bonne idée du stress que c'était une
bonne idée d'un pull c'est finalement ce
retour à l'école quand on voit que
quasiment six mois plus tard on efface
toujours cette crise sanitaire et on
voit que la jeunesse souffre énormément
et que cette continuité pédagogique en
présentiel permet un petit peu quand
même
d'adoucir d'adoucir la note
c'était au mois de juin sur le débat
était différent le débat s'était rouvrir
des lycées pour bijoux aux dix jours
avec des conseils de classe qui avait la
plupart du temps eu lieu et si j'avais
pris cette position en disant n'ouvrons
que là où c'est vraiment nécessaire on
m'avait cité par exemple l'histoire des
classes préparatoires c'est parce que
les proviseurs eux mêmes
avait évoqué cette question bien comment
faire revenir des élèves en classe quand
au bout du compte il ya plus dangereux
parce que l'année scolaire est terminée
donc les faire revenir un jour ou deux
jours pour reprendre contact avec leurs
preuves pour préparer l'année suivante
oui et d'ailleurs en bout du compte
c'est ce qui s'est passé ouvrir les
lycées comme le gouvernement l'a non
c'est totalement pleinement alors que il
restait huit jours de scolarité j'avais
trouvé ça tout de même un peu curieux
bon ben voilà c'est ce que jean-michel
journée aujourd'hui il faut tout faire
pour maintenir l'écouté mois je m'en
vais je regarde le taux de contamination
dans nos personnels qui sont qui
travaillent dans les lycées comme vous
le savez ils sont très nombreux c'est
c'est plus de 2 c environ trois mille
cinq cents agents
on a très très peu de contamination on
en a un tout petit peu plus par rapport
aux semaines suivant des précédentes
mais mais très peu donc en clair
aujourd'hui
rien n'indique que les protocoles
sanitaires qui ont été mises en place
dans les lycées soit défaillant
puisqu'on a dans nos personnels très
très peu d'agents qui sont qui sont
contaminés un mot sur un autre sujet
c'est ce passeport vert qui doit être
présenté aujourd'hui à bruxelles c'est
une sorte de passeport vaccinale pour
faciliter les voyages au sein de l'union
européenne qui doit être mis en place
avant l'été il faudra dire si on est
vacciné si on est guéri si on est testé
négatif au cabinet ce que ça c'est une
bonne idée pour vous notamment pour
relancer le tourisme et le tourisme en
normandie je pense que toute façon comme
on dirait en normandie on n'y coupera
pas
le je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de pays
qui réclameront en effet un document sur
votre état vaccinal et que donc l'idée
selon laquelle ce serait une atteinte
majeure à nos libertés et est sera en
quelque sorte
confronté à quelque chose de simple
c'est que beaucoup de pays vous
demanderont est ce que vous êtes vacciné
ou est ce que au moins vous êtes tester
ce qui est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
j'ajoute que j'ai encore le souvenir
mais c'est peut-être des réflexes de
vieux c'est que on avait un petit livre
région ne suis pas si vous souvenez vous
êtes trop jeune mais monsieur rhabiller
doit s'en souvenir
un petit un petit livret jaune qu'on
devait avoir lorsqu'on partait moi j'ai
beaucoup voyagé quand j'avais entre 20
et 30 ans à travers le monde et j'avais
je suis pourquoi la fièvre jaune je sais
plus quoi des vaccinations qui était
obligatoire mais très franchement a pas
le sentiment qu'à travers ça on se
retrouvait face à une contrainte majeure
on va revenir sur c'est un endroit vide
puisque c'était il ya un an jour pour
jour que débuter le 1er confinement on
va parler des relations entre l'état et
les élus locaux qu'est ce que ça a
changé cette année de co vite pour vos
relations est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que le gouvernement
il a tiré les leçons durant cette crise
sanitaire et ça a amélioré sa a dégradé
les relations entre état élus locaux t
on à voilà on a pense que tous nos
compatriotes ont désormais clairement
une évidence c'est que l'état
centralisée bureaucratisée qui aurait pu
être une chance dans une crise comme
celle ci en se disant on va voir un
système planifié centralisé qui va
fonctionner
comme un jardin à la française à la
prussienne et c'est que tout ça beaucoup
disent fonctionné et que les
collectivités locales ont tout fait
preuve de réactivité de capacité
d'adaptation d'intelligence collective
et qu'une des grandes conclusions de la
crise et qu'il faut changer notre modèle
dans un pays qui est le pays où la
dépense publique est la plus élevée au
monde
on aurait pu penser au moins que durant
cette période ça allait marcher
ça n'est clairement pas le cas et tous
ces dysfonctionnements on les a tous en
tête
exemple avec le premier but de premier
ministre pendant cette crise est ce que
ça se passe mieux moins bien avec jean
castex fait avec edouard philippe
comment ça se passe au début on a on a
pensé qu'elle jean castex aller mieux se
passer parce que ça se passait pas très
très bien avec edouard philippe
et au bout du compte très franchement ça
n'a pas beaucoup changé
je serais même presque prêt à dire que
certains engagements qui avaient été
pris par le gouvernement d'edouard
philippe n'ont même pas été tenus par
jean castex reprend un très simple que
thierry rhabiller connaît le contrat de
plan edouard philippe avait décidé à
notre demande et géant au titre du bon
sens que nous soyons en quelque sorte
dans la construction d'un contrat de
plan c'est à dire des grands programmes
d'investissement cofinancé par la région
et l'état dans une démarche ascendante
c'est à dire chaque territoire face le
constat de ces faiblesses de ses besoins
et que donc on n'est pas un système qui
soit descendant avec les administrations
les peuples et les budgets programmés et
paf on fait une répartition par région à
partir de critères complètement
nationaux et bien edouard philippe nous
avait dit ok on va faire une démarche
nouvelle on va bâtir ensemble des
contrats de plan qui partent d'un
constat commun préfet de région
président de région et au bout du compte
on s'est retrouvé qu'un contrat de plan
qui est exactement l inverse
ce qui est absolument contre ait eu à
nous on entendit on a un vrai besoin
c'est améliorer l'attractivité de nos
universités s'est rattrapé notre retard
dans les équipements en année
ce programme d'un milliard d'euros sur
dix ans pour bâtir notamment deux grands
campus et est donc conforté le troisième
campus celui du lard bien et au bout du
compte on se retrouve avec des niveaux
de critiques extrêmement faibles
accordées par l'état sur ce qui était
pour nous la priorité de la priorité et
quand je dis simplement pour que vous
compreniez à l'état dégagé moins 30 ou
40 millions d'euros des routes pour me
mettre sur les universités l'italien ans
on peut pas faire ça parce que ce serait
un pressant d'un précédent et qu'après
on sera obligé de rediscuter sur nombre
de sujets mais sa semaine entre ou
intelligent on est et on est très loin
d'une décentralisation il ya une loi
cadets qui va être content et ressort
que semaine après les faits vous allez à
la hauteur très faible très très faible
on parle pas du tout déçu dessous des
changements d'ailés shiloh jour non pas
du tout et ces va et c'est un constat
partagé par la totalité des structures
représentant les collectivités locales
quelle que soit la couleur politique de
2 2 lors de leur président franchement
on a un texte très décevant alors on
attend beaucoup du sénat pour améliorer
le texte est donnée un peu d'imagination
gouvernement on va à parler des dossiers
régionaux avant d'en parler avec thierry
à un mot sur l'écotaxe puisque les
députés ont ouvert la porte au retour de
l'écotaxe cette contribution poids
lourds mais en la laissant la main des
régions est ce que vous en normandie
vous êtes favorable à ce retour de
l'écotaxe vous pensez que je vais
adopter faire voter par l'assemblée
régionale une écotaxe certains de vos
collègues présidents de région c'est
bien quand ils sont frontaliers avec
l'allemagne ça ça valait 10 maîtresses
par exemple valérie pécresse est très
bien mais moi je suis dans une région au
j'ai quand même des grands ports où j'ai
une économie dans laquelle il faut de la
logistique se fait quoi je je je je j'ai
déjà une économie régionale qui est
comme toutes les économies
voilà sur sur la ligne de crête où sur
le fil du rasoir et voudriez que je
plombe un secteur économique majeur pour
la région je préfère largement intégré
l'idée qu'on
être la grande région de l'hydrogène
qu'on puisse bâtir un modèle dans lequel
très rapidement on puisse commencer à
expérimenter le transport logistique
avec notamment l'hydrogène par exemple
on va parler des questions régionales
thierry oui donc si on joue aussi on a
bien écouté bien compris vous attendait
toujours une réponse de l'état
concernant le fléchage des des millions
sur l'enseignement supérieur en or ni
toujours pas de réponse
en revanche est ce que vous avez une
réponse du ministre des transports
concernant votre nouveau tour de table
que vous proposez pour financer le
périphérique donneront suite au
renoncement de la métropole d'apporter
ses 66 millions pour ce projet
autoroutier ce que ce que je crois
savoir c'est que l'état attend la
décision du le vote du département de la
seine maritime sur sa contribution
complémentaire pour compenser le retrait
de la métropole de rouen et c'est
ensuite que nous aurons des discussions
avec les deux autres questions sur les
entreprises
les défaillances d'entreprises dont on
parlait tout à l'heure tu iras redon oui
au ca secret de polichinelle et on sait
très bien que le département on va voter
cette subvention supplémentaire donc
l'état ne fait un petit peut que
repousser l'inéluctable c'est de prendre
une décision et je vous laisse je vous
donne le numéro de portable de jean
baptiste djebbari et vous lui ferez
savoir mais moi le lait les échos que
nous avons du ministère des transports
c'est que ils attendent la décision
définitive du département de
seine-maritime et ensuite la discussion
aura lieu on est encore dans les délais
dans le calendrier
ce les entreprises ses riffs oui vous
êtes à la manoeuvre sur le plan
économique depuis plusieurs mois depuis
un an pour justement à améliorer la
situation économique des entreprises
la normandie n'est pas épargné vous
suivez des dossiers lourds en ce moment
le dossier du site de vallourec sur des
villes dans le dossier de manoir
industries
dans l'heure un département où
connaissez bien qu'est ce que peut faire
un président de région pour lutter
contre ces fermetures qui semble
inéluctable ou à chaque fois on est sur
une des centaines d'emplois qui risquent
d'être détruits sur un territoire qui
déjà souffre se plaindre du chômage
écoutez on est deux entre vallourec et
manoir industries d'ailleurs on n'est
pas dans la même situation
notre auteur du sur l'état l'état qui
est défaillant et sur le dos de l'autre
dossier manoir industries sur un
actionnaire chinois qu'il faille encore
effectivement on est sur deux dossiers
de dimensions différentes assure manoir
industries j'ai de bons espoirs
nous avons bâti un modèle permettant la
reprise de l'entreprise qui je crois est
en capacité de tenir la route je ne peux
pas trop vous en dira pas ce que l'on
n'est pas il nous reste plus qu'un sujet
à régler sujet taille qu'est la question
de l'immobilier sur lequel on a fait des
propositions et donc en clair la balle
est dans le camp du propriétaire du
foncier et de l'immobilier de pîtres 3-2
manoir industries et si cette
question-là trouve une solution et il
n'y a pas de raison qu'on ne trouve pas
de solution on doit être en capacité de
sauver l'entreprise sas et je crois je
crois possible sur vallourec honnêtement
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire au pdg de
vallourec
c'est cette entreprise se comporte très
mal quand j'ai quand je suis allé
rencontrer le président de vallourec
maman il nous a expliqué que
l'écosystème industriels allemands
étaient meilleures et donc y
renforçaient que c'est plus facile en
allemagne donc qu'il renforçait son
outil industriel en allemagne j'ai dit
moi je souvenirs à xavier bertrand
d'avoir rencontré le patron dessous de
soccer quand il nous a fermé deux usines
de production de 2,2 de sucre et les
deux fois
il nous a expliqué que lui littéralement
et que d'abord et avant tout il sauver
ses usines en allemagne et je lui dis
mais est-ce quinze jours vous vous
comporterez un peu en patriote en
pensant que si vallourec est encore
debout c'est parce que l'état a soutient
vallourec est d'avoir un réflexe de
temps à autre nationale 2 de se dire je
suis français est ce que c'est si
compliqué que ça quand on est pdg d'une
boîte de se dire le siège social de
cette boîte et est en france à boulogne
toute l'histoire industrielle de
vallourec est liée à l'histoire de la
france et donc je vais faire en sorte
qu'on privilégie d'abord la france c'est
pas moi ça me paraît tellement évident
ou quoi et dernière question de tirer
sur les régionales thierry avant de vous
laisser la parole on va regarder
ensemble ce dernier sondage hervé morin
sondage ifop pour le parti communiste
qui vous donnent en tête 1 31% suivie de
nicolas bay pour le rassemblement
national à 24% et sébastien jumel pour
le parti communiste à 14 % tiré une
question oui justement vous êtes vous
êtes déjà quasiment en campagne ou à
lancer une plateforme participative
convoyer ce sondage qui vous donne tous
en tête
est-ce que clairement ou dit le jeux
sont faits et je repars pour 6 ans et
avec quel projet écoutez je suis
rhabillé l'avantagé que j'ai appris une
chose c'est qu'une élection n'était
jamais gagné voilà et j'ai toujours été
beaucoup d'humilité face à face au
suffrage universel donc en clair au
moins si si je vous donnais un un
sondage que chacun ait fait la région on
a toutes satisfactions sur la politique
régionale qui est très élevé mais je
sais que ce n'est pas sur un bilan qu'on
est élu mais sur un projet est donc très
clairement je présenterai à la fois ce
que nous avons réalisé parce que nos
compatriotes ne le savent pas toujours
et de l'autre nous aurons l'occasion de
présenter mais pas avant le moine est un
projet des propositions nouvelles vous
verrez il ya des choses assez décapante
et à ces nouvelles pour pour la
normandie dans ce projet mais chaque
chose en son temps mais vous viendrez
nous en parler mais je pense que
monsieur rabia m'habitera dans les
colonnes de son journal
ben on espère que vous avez aussi sur le
plateau avec cyril aviez merci thierry
on regarde la une de paris normandie
c'est un normand qui fait rêver la
france entière est la une de paris
normandie c'est thomas pesquet oui on
l'avait reçue on avait filles on avait
fait une manifestation avec les jeunes
et alors la popularité thomas pesquet et
l'intelligence de ce2 de cet homme est
absolument extraordinaire et il est à la
une de paris normandie fisichella avait
reçu effectivement et puis après on
l'avait reçue glissant on l'avait reçue
avec les jeunes et 4000 jeunes qui
l'avaient cavic avait discuté avec lui
tu as écrit les doubles à la une de
paris normandie merci beaucoup terreau
est habillé d'avoir été avec nous et
merci à hervé morin d'avoir été notre
invité ce matin parce que tito club des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
présente le club des territoires angie
acteurs engagés dans la transition zéro
carbone des régions vous présente le
club des territoires
[Musique]